have you heard of the other theories of
consciousness like the integrated
information theory and daniel denetz and
so on what do you think of them well
let's go iit
i think that iit is
several things so it starts out if you
look at the axioms of iit with the
phenomenologist description of
consciousness it describes what
consciousness feels like from the inside
so for instance you have this
impression over here and now
and this uh here and now is distinct
from the physical here and now i think
something that uh iit as far as i'm
aware doesn't really emphasize but it's
pretty clear that uh from the
perspective of the here and now in
consciousness uh the physical universe
is is not in that here and now and
cannot be
because we often construct the conscious
experience after the fact
or predictively
which means the the here and now of
physics is uh smeared out
right and
we are able to experience things
consciously that don't happen physically
not just because we are simplifying them
but uh because we feed emerge the
features of our models in a way that is
not compatible with the physical
universe but that is useful to the
control of the physical universe so
basically the contents of our
consciousness are determined by what
makes up useful control model not by
what's physically possible and what's
physically happening
the other aspect of iit is
its denial of functionalism so iit in
some sense is
makes metaphysical assumptions
and these metaphysical assumptions
i suspect amount to pancychism
which means that
consciousness is in some sense
inseparable from matter or from the
background of the universe therefore it
must be an intrinsic property of matter
itself you could say imagine you
cannot just determine what color is and
if you look with with the microscope is
you cannot see what color is made of
right color doesn't have components so
uh color must be an intrinsic part of
matter color is not made by matter it's
inseparable for matter every matter
contains color right right this is
almost correct but it's not because uh
if you zoom in at a certain point there
is no more color
color only makes sense as a kind of
interpretation of what we sense about
matter and i think that's also true for
consciousness
right
consciousness only exists within minds
not within the physical universe and so
in some sense iit i think is putting the
locus of consciousness into a domain
where it doesn't belong
and then there are the technical aspects
of the implementation of uh
the i t series uh iit that is this
factor phi the measure of integration
and uh there are some good aspects about
this so
in the sense that
your own neocortex is
integrating information in such a way
that when a lot of it is synchronized
and is
stored in an intentional protocol then
you will probably have a larger focus of
your attentional awareness than when you
have when your consciousness is highly
fragmented and your this will be
reflected in the fragmentation of the
cortical contents which means that a lot
of it is not firing in synchrony and
this is being described to some degree
by phi but uh this is a relatively small
aspect in this of of phi and i think if
you go deeper and try to make more out
of phi then it falls apart because you
it's no longer necessary in sufficient
condition you don't know what gradual
states of phi mean and so on
so i i don't think that i buy iit at
this point it's not explaining how this
phenomenon comes about
and it's
descriptive
and it has
metaphysics that cannot be evidenced
that are not predictive